what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are about to kick off our reactions
for Henry cavill's last season of The Witcher um
I'm not as excited as I would like to be mainly
because I'm aware the best part of the show is
leaving yeah it's hard to yeah cope with that
yeah but it's his last season so I figured why not
just go in with like an open mind obviously and uh
have a little bit of a Bittersweet experience
I suppose and uh hopefully uh it ends up being
really enjoyable that's my best wish I'm not going
in here to be like hyper critical or something
like that we even liked the season that a lot of
people didn't like which was season two so it's
by no means a thing about the show it's just the
fact that Henry Cavill is leaving which has made
the experience a bit dejecting is all but let's be
professional ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
toss a coin to the like button also subscribe
click that notification Bell to get notified when
I react for the next episode of The Witcher is up
here on this channel this is the first episode so
uh you know usually full introduction watch
laundry stick it with your own copy available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon page but
because it's the first episode that one is made
public and so if you want to sync up watch along
with us uh there's a link in the description box
and pin comments so you don't need to pledge to
our patreon page for the first episode so please
just go ahead and use that if you'd like
Anyway let's see what this episode is like
we're seeking a girl and a Witcher masterians will
recompense you handsomely for illumination as
to their whereabouts because he's a fire guy
looking for me
[Music]
dude
ah damn look at that CGI blood it's gotten
better it's got more weight to it I am petunia
um
it's like out of a video game
nice that head fell incredibly
gracefully to the ground
for your discretion thank
you I will not count this
anything helps I will do everything in
my power to help Siri grow her magical
skill it's going to be a long road ahead
for all of us your friend Jennifer I'm
officially in the friend zone dear friend
she has great potential but little Talent
it's okay she mastered The Witcher course
Knows My Name
wow I mean it's not like you burned
their actual home down yeah I mean you
could probably repurpose this place pretty
easily I could have just left it let it be
for your discretion I will not count it
anything helps any little Satchel of coin
I assume is plenty the honor System is what
we abide by this is Trope of these kind of
fantasy movies and shows I've always loved
would never counted people know the weight
of the right amount of coin dear friend it seems
that you and Syria thoroughly enjoying our fourth
house in as many months finding time to bond so
delightfully I will remind you though that you
asked nay begged me to teach her magic uh-oh
someone's starting to become bitter I'm Eric
Siri taketh away
[Music]
slaughter them Siri tell
yennefer we're leaving [Laughter]
and I expect payment for my discretion just any
Satchel will do just let me hear the sound of the
coins we're good we're so far off the map here
that we may never leave again we'll continue
magic lessons before the ice melts I promise
but for now perhaps the girl deserves a break
just having fun with me now so it's okay I've
been wanting to invite me to dinner ever since
we arrived yeah bye no but I look through your
window and you have more wine and I'm begging for
really far isn't it girls fill it with your urine
dear friend that's not wine you're drinking yeah
look at them oh it's like when
families on the edge are divorce
during covid finally managed to make
things work got no choice otherwise
[Music]
I am enjoying this simplistic bonding
of them before things becoming crazy
you know convoluted plots before all
the plot lines converge prophecies
automatic is tricky that's what you said
about Earth Magic and air magic what do
you have power like nothing I've seen
I think so hard for both of us try fire
how could Fire magic be any worse
with Fire magic the source is you
take something you never get back your magic yes
oh a built-in festival's just down the valley you
should come I'd love to it's not a bad idea and
everyone will be in costume what could go wrong
oh my fresh Chum for you
now see how you like my new pets
whoa that one hurt that jacket pace
is trying to smell your kind from a
league away then I've come to the
right place uh I need to find a
girl with Elven blood oh my Japanese
is a sense I'll do you one better
oh is that the same actor I can't tell is
that Liam Hemsworth she is out of there
have there been sightings or are we chasing
more rumors we don't know yeah Galadriel I
will find dobathana but how there is
no Sanctuary left for elves here all
the become clear once we have cerrilla she is
our new hope Siri you could unite everything
he doesn't need you to play nurse
maid he needs you to play Soldier
Medics Are Soldiers too is that Robbie Amell
he looked familiar maybe the whole continent
is our doorbell we tried sharing the continent for
centuries if there's to be another genocide this
time it'll be the humans don't worry global
warming is gonna take care of everything
you promised me a princess you swore
cirilla would be mine perhaps a tad go
out to your highness we wouldn't
want your beloved to catch wind
our attention has been diverted because of
the squirrels oh yeah more excuses they're
blaming us for murdering that stupid
elephant baby it definitely wasn't ours
a spymaster who can't find one girl now it's
time for exchange right of it what's that
this is gonna go great as for Prince seed
waste all departure I'm not gonna order
someone to babysit the prince while he
flits about looking to the girl we don't
trust anyone else we're actually gonna see
this guy's personality a little more yeah
if I do this I'll be the only
one giving orders when I get back
this will definitely help differentiate
from his house of the Dragon character
what do you think I think you need to hide
your hair and mask your eyes would it kill
you to say you look lovely you look like a
no daughter of mine my name's got a bad idea
oh you look hot you're so
hot [Music] it looks lovely
nice let's do some Eyes Wide Shut look at what
happens when we let her have one good night
let's not pretend your motivations aren't Italian
selfish Jennifer happy birthday to you too
oh you do care say you remember our good
night after the gin season one call back
the overnight carriage ride from ellender to Moen
the Beltane Festival in the mornings they
were lonely you're often left before Dawn
oh you did but then one time girls
did remember you guys remember
scared what would happen if we really tried
I was unsure it was actually what I wanted not
just some trick of the Jen's Magic and now I
[Music] oh these always go well
never turns into a psychological
nightmare yeah you're not gonna
have some kind of vision in here
hahaha [Laughter] cut through the hedges man
it is it's like a big old monster pill bug yeah
damn [Music] raining paid off damn
strength
catch it in a magic jar
staying at the right spot squelch intensifies we
draw him out we give him the thing he wants most
you have a caravan leaving tomorrow don't you
I want to go with you but it's important that
no one knows that for us this plan isn't going
to work tell me what I need to do get her on the
care of it without the listening we need you
to complain about the spoiled brat who ruined
belting for everyone now I have to hold that Ava
brat Palace all the way to Aiden with my Caravan
no they'll know who you're talking about you
think this Mage is going to believe that you
let Siri raid with an escort she'll be traveling
with someone we trust seemingly innocuous oh come
on yes yes my man is what we do my sweet
we are creatives free thinkers All is fair
I am doing everything that I can we invested a
lot in your operations and we've gotten nothing
in return deeksha and I are ready to cut you
loose what is this new or am I forgetting
something like what did you fall in with them
look at me look at my eyes there is no need to
harm the innocent that's it this guy's not so
bad oh cirilla girl has enemies everywhere is
not a bad place humid in the summer but the
food is spectacular oh he's actually good at
his job yeah so far you could be a robot no no a
stayed life at court is not for me if your time at
court has been stayed you've been doing it wrong
dang it's a persuasive guy deliver the girl or we
will single-handedly undo Every Good
Deed you have done for the elves you
five days and I remember helping the elves this
season feels so much more modern yeah yeah even
in some of the ways they talk and stuff yeah your
friends need help of course they do it's a tight
spot alaran Brave and inspiring Elven Warrior who
thought she could defeat the humans she was wrong
they always are after the
conjunction humans arrived
the elves thought the humans were just a nuisance
sure but they would die off in the blink of an
Elven eye but the humans kept multiplying as we
do like a disease sounds like she thought what she
believed in she did fight for what she believed
in she let those young and passionate elves to war
at this place this is where they fought of
how much of a father he's become yeah gotta
fat you up need you back out there food goes
to the ones who fought all elves share equally
otherwise we're no better than the humans we
are socialists it seems like this guy is going
to be starting his own faction of elves ask
where tail forces should be United what did
you see out there to change your mind I
simply had time to consider your position
[Music] three you two really think
I'm that shitty of a god another dream
sleep thinking about Halloran and my
grandmother burned with the exact same mission
looking off for something different a way
forward that doesn't divide but unites
exactly I understand both because I am both and
that is my strength yes yes I have the power to
change the cycle of hatred and I want to because
I am sick and tired of Destruction and loss
I don't doubt you Siri I too
doubt the world though it
requires an action yes it's just one big
action scene out there I got so much more
Hands-On and affectionate yeah it's meant
to be a father she can do this [Music]
hey I've brought more friends this time
you could do this Siri remember your
Witcher training stormy my magic foreign
[Music] that frame rate
I like my arms I like how old's better
go team
that's not good
are you sure you sent him to the right place
all right good
we just need to wait for goat oh no
hey oh [__] what's up team
oh no Dara
so she's always been so badass
I don't look so special yeah just hurt my feelings
[Laughter]
feel that one
you call yourself an elf she's a
quarter elf she belongs with me
damn your Majors out of her death
where'd his sword go
use it
[Music]
preventing him from being
able to do stuff now yeah
oh oh nice oh sweet oh my God this
is great the way the way he moves
[Music] wow
wow that was great choreography that cavel
whoa yeah
dang I hope you got to eat before that you'll be
fine your loots on the other hand has seen better
days it's okay isn't the only Rogue mate we're
dealing with someone very powerful is puppeting
him I need help oh I can talk to you no you don't
know how difficult it is to embody power but not
have access to it going to aratuza cannot be
the only answer it's the best thing for her
is it or for you yes I need to finally answer to
finish him off I can't go with you and we can't
go with you France just feels like a nuisance and
not much of a threat yeah figure for for all the
build up lessons it just seems kind of like a
guy who shows up to get in your way Tennessee
lost her brother and I have
lost a dozen more she lied to us
as I wonder we need her everyone needs her she
brings nothing but death the problem isn't her
that's that one I've had enough where are
you going to get help from an old friend
I have no idea who he could be referring
to who haven't we seen yet I've got her
yeah and I say this isn't goodbye for good
that there are more good nights to come
yes that you will of me that's my problem to you
no a new excuse this time I'll do it serious in
danger and so the people around her it would be
best she landed somewhere safe nowhere is safe
Mage with a fondness for fire brilliant get
rid of them you will have earned series Trust
and girls and might in that
order you're good at this game
if you say sick babe yes odd character dear friend
I wrote you but you still ain't calling [Laughter]
should I say we
sides are a Tuesday is not to her liking I have
my eyes on our next home a dollhouse on a squid
Farm oh yes friend and left after all those good
nights because I was scared for the first time I
understand real fear oh his hair is very dry for
that rain I'm just uncertain on this continent
oh I will learn to trust you again
you Siri and I We Belong Together
finally oh boy
no cherish her memory
just wants his daughter I know
[Music]
and he burned those screenshots from season one
hey
well
um that's cool yeah yeah that's cool or or back in
the world doing stuff feels like a part three it
does see yeah that's a good way to put that it's
got a little bit of a different way of moving it's
got a little bit of different way of speaking
and it's trying to like hit you real quick with
a whole bunch of stakes don't let people get bored
yeah don't let people get bored yeah speed it up
this is so fast paced like for Witcher standards
especially yeah this was so fast yeah yeah and
after at least the first kind of Chunk where
you're like living with them for a little bit
and even though it's hopping through time and
places they're living like At first you're like
okay I'm kind of getting into the and then like
once things really pop off it's like wow you're
just getting everybody back in the game yeah
yeah yeah even we're at like ultimate because
they split this up into two two parts which
I'm not sure what the purpose was for that
um so I thought it'd be even slower yeah when
you do something like that but this was so it's
just so quick and like think about everything
that I can't even possibly recap every single
thing that happened in here um but yeah that
it was really the pacing was it was the most
jarring part to me because the writing and
the dialogue seemed so much more modern than
before and I know those they were already like
kind of transitioning there with season two
where it was feeling more accessible because I
remember season one it was a little bit of a okay
trying to like brain on him notes pretend you're
reading it there's a lot to keep up with here
um and then season two that did make it easier
to digest and um you know just keep up with
what's happening but here it was like I kind of
likened some of the experience of this too how I
was feeling with Mandalorian season three oh this
is really fast and it's it's more fun it's a lot
more action uh and I didn't I I I still enjoyed
it though I don't want to just seem like I'm I'm
just dogging on it to dog on it or something I
I still enjoyed it for the most part uh the the
the acting still good they're the um I like I
like that's Rafael I just gotta look that up
right yeah yeah go look it up yeah it looked
pretty sure and when he showed up I was like
wait a minute like yeah he looks super familiar
yeah so uh and Witcher have you type that in yeah
you know I don't know I wouldn't be surprised
we're gonna get the Liam Hemsworth treatment
soon for Robbie seems like he would be just
just as easy to slide in on the heels of an
announcement like that oh yeah let me see here it
was Robbie melon Witcher yeah yeah yeah he plays
um Gallop yeah he plays Gallatin is the guy's name
gotcha and then I'm going to check if rants has
been recast because that character too like when
uh yeah okay so it is a different casting on him
as well and that character like when he
showed up in the previous I was like okay
like at the outset you're like ooh fire Mage
forbidden magic this guy's gonna be twisted
and uh and yeah now here it kind of feels
just like ah you know he's a guy who shows
up to give us a fight once in a while and
that's about it I mean I hope it results in
something a little bit more than that but
I think they just wanted this one to be
Swift and entertaining because I felt like it was
really devoid of tension and Stakes the entire
time which is something Witcher really needs it
really needs that especially when the plot is
like last season ends off with everyone wants
Siri yeah that is and the reveal of um her dad
you know like all that is it was a great ending uh
for it and a great setup and I mean obviously it's
still the plot here yet you know by the time you
get to that finale where ever everyone shows up
that should be like intense and high stakes yeah
and it's just sort of uh fleetingly entertaining
with some occasional cool sort of play you
know and I'll admit yeah it's a little bit
um it's a little bit weak to me is it possible
see there's on the weaker side of Witcher for sure
yeah I mean it just doesn't feel as
substantial like there is I don't know like not
they're clearly out of the position where they
feel like they have to keep up with like the
tonal elements of like living I feel like The
Witcher show was probably at first brought to
light as you know kind of Netflix going we need
our Game of Thrones and I feel like earlier on
in the show there was a more literary feeling tone
where it's like you would kind of stay in a place
and you would feel its Vibes you would kind of
it doesn't feel right no exactly it's like this
feels like actors playing dress-up now yeah they
would go a long way in earlier at least in the
first it's kind of you know it's become yeah more
blockbustery as you know season two and now season
three at least at the start you know kind of feels
as it has gone on but yeah I feel like you need
some of those elements of you know taking the time
to live in the world and stew in these character
beats and stuff like that because especially for
what Siri is going through I mean yeah like they
start to feel now like the family in some kind of
medieval Adventure movie rather than you know this
fated Trio who has been you know across so many
different timelines and and prophecies and and you
know Arrangements of fate and blah blah like yeah
now it sort of feels like well everybody likes the
three of them together so we gotta you know like
really ride that family Dynamic and then split
them up yeah split them up so that we have that's
our tension because that's what people want is
they want Ninja to get back to baby Yoda now and
that's that's our but they were like they just got
we didn't re-watch it okay they didn't
all come to converge together the three
main characters until the end of last season
right yeah it was the end of last season yeah
and now they're divided again except of course
you know yeah they have this whole thing yeah
they're one of their locations with
the witches you know yeah sure yeah
um cool yeah uh I I thought I liked the I thought
it was as what it really played well on is the
fact that I just I like the performers and I
like the characters especially our three leads
and I like the world generally generally I like
the world yeah so it was mainly working off of
that like my favorite parts of it were actually
just them hanging out and bonding and having
a good time like that that was my my favorite
part is spanning that time and the letters that
those some of my favorite parts of the of this
whole episode and seeing geralt be a lot more
express it like he's been so stoic all
these seasons and now you could feel the
note of this season girl it's gonna be a lot more
emotionally available he's going to open himself
up now he's the Ultimate Fantasy character
he's like you he's a totally nurturing he's
Joel from the last of the Year Dad of the
year but he can still slice people up yeah
yeah he's really he's a lot more open even the
way how he's reserved and standoffish towards uh
and not Syria uh Jennifer the way he stand office
towards her uh even there it's like at least not
totally I mean look at it you know him he's a big
soft you know this is still flirting yeah it's a
little bit more soap opera in the way they handle
it it's a lot of that that was kind of sort of
charming to me other than the the cutesiness of
it like it was way cuter than before yeah uh it
did feel like they were this lack of living in it
and a lot of telling me what I should be thinking
and feeling the whole time well there's just so
much more dialogue that is plot oriented and and
I mean we're joking about Recaps at the beginning
but like recap oriented and and I just feel like
yeah this was the kind of sh it feels like every
season's at a different showrunner maybe they have
uh I don't know who the showrunners are but each
one has felt like it was like watching The Walking
Dead like yeah it starts to change each time you
come back and each sensibility they approach it
with and here yeah like there's not doesn't really
feel like there was much character meat on any of
the dialogue especially they were they were saying
stuff though to provide characters yeah I realize
now what I need is what I fear is losing you guys
and what my motion like that's what everyone was
so I everyone had a note for what they wanted
for their character this season and then they
just said the note yes like they don't this isn't
a show so much right now or it's not presenting
as a show that's about scenes and about really
building this lore and really you know weaving
this intricate web of convoluted but like there's
there's an art to yeah coming up with all these
you know places and factions of people and
finding a way to get you caught up in all of
it rather than just having it be like okay wait
who are these people again and what do they want
they all kind of wants the same mumbo jumbo
thing are they gonna kill her they got a user
um and yeah it's like this kind of felt like
okay you know we've got this prologue that's
got everything everybody likes which is three of
them and then it's just like Hey we're gonna hit
you with like familiar characters and we're gonna
jump around and you know I feel like this could
have been a couple episodes worth of material
and let it breathe yeah because I was like oh
this should be a bummer that they're splitting
apart yeah and the like the things there's so
much plot happening at this point I'm like I feel
like sure you montage over it but I don't really
it's a little Revel in the Beltane celebration
like it should be a big moment for Siri because
it is her birthday and it is like a she has been
in hiding and feeling this angst of having to move
everywhere and as much as I don't want it to be
like a soap opera of like you guys never let me
do anything but we have to protect you like
you know it would have been nice to Revel in
some of those feelings have some conflict and
even in that moment where they're attacked and
the big creature shows up and then they leave
again like it still doesn't quite truly feel
like there was like a huge risk of life or some
kind of you know shattering like damn it this was
our this is what we finally found at home yeah
it just feels like ah we gotta keep this thing
moving you know yeah yeah I don't really like
yeah I don't know what's the name rents here
uh the fire guy yeah uh rants is what
they're going with this same guy yeah
a different actor same guy same difference
yeah so it is a different actor yeah okay
um yeah I'm not a big fan of of of I mean I
remember liking him in season two uh but I
liked the performer no no shade to the new actor
but I did like that performer enough to like that
character it doesn't feel threatening um at all
and the character who I did like a lot though
who which the one that surprised me is the the
brother to the king yes he was a really nice
surprise because he is just so bored but he's that
guy who could just show up but because he's bored
he's but he's so confident in a way that is so
natural yeah because it's a it's that confidence
that stems from I just don't care enough yeah
you know yeah um then when he when he shows up
like I loved his introduction we were like oh
god king God is Idiot Brother on it and then he
starts talking and he asking you're like oh never
mind this guy's like freaking amazing at what he
does he's a persuasive guy yeah yeah using that
that sort of I that whatever that is that that
like oh this guy might not be very bright to his
Advantage yeah this like apathetic quality that
he has that was really great yeah it was the one
engrossing it was the one engrossing character
thing because they threw somebody at you who yeah
you have this initial impression of and then over
the few scenes we get him and I was like okay so
is this guy just like smarter and more Charming
than he looks and then at the end I'm like is this
guy actually a lot more like skeevy and depraved
than he lets on like yeah and and this I feel like
that's a type of character too who like especially
can lend you know your pulp and your uh like
really uncomfortable so like I feel like these
shows more so than even a lot of modern shows are
populated by these like feral people who you know
can present as you have to bored or amused but
are secretly like sick and twisted inside and
and that was the one character where I felt like
man I want to know what's inside this guy like I
want to know who this guy really is I was out
of outside of our main Trio whenever we cut to
him I was most interested yeah I mean I like the
main Trio because we like the main Trio and I like
yeah skier because I like yaskir but even hear
something they wrote him like he's a fan favorite
it wrote him like a lot of the way of the writing
was in this episode was was very off to me you
see I I heard the complaint about the writing with
them not being adherent to the source material yes
I don't know what here is accurate to the source
material I'm talking just about General writing
right now yeah and um that was very off to me
this entire episode uh I don't know editing
and writing was just way off to me and and so
to me that's where I was like ooh not a good
sign Henry Cavill of course is is as awesome of
a presence as always and he's got that benefit of
he's got that the I had a brief
sometimes an actor sticks around
for a show and you could tell they're
bored and they want to leave the show
and eventually they leave the show you
know but they're just getting a paycheck
the benefit of Henry Cavill is even if geralt
looks bored you're like but that could just
be the character sure because it's scary yeah
sorry either wait I don't I don't feel like he's
not committed I'm not I'm not saying that it's
just sometimes you have a behind and I feel like
this show this show more than ever especially
knowing that they've already got a replacement
um and like everyone knows that you might observe
some of the performance with that like is he still
here like is he still truly invested he seems
invested uh but uh but anytime he seems like he's
not invested I'm like they could just be careful
you know yeah yeah no no and it's a testament to
his presence as an actor and and what he has been
able to maintain like because yeah in a situation
like that it makes me wonder because yeah if he
is bored I think he's doing a very professional
job at it because it's still engrossing to watch
him and and I think the character also benefits
from not being the most talkative guy so there are
times when you get to just watch him be yeah yeah
um but at the same time yeah I mean part of me
wonders about the recasting part of me wonder
you know just looking at this and then looking
at stuff from before I feel like I could fathom
how as an actor you might be less enthused about
the current scripts sure and what they're giving
you to work with especially knowing that Cavill
is such a big Witcher fan and it you know was
like really gunning for this role and how much
he cares about geralt definitely and you know
the other drama about like do the writers really
hate the books you know right right yeah it's just
yeah it makes it takes me out of just being
invested in the moment of the show and makes
me wonder things like that yeah man oh well it's
an odd odd one but fun like you said this is fun
yeah I was I was um
I didn't quite hit board yeah yeah so nor
was I like very entertained they're like
this is working this cookies is really I was
never like this is really fun nor was I like
I am bored out of my mind right now no I
was always intrigued and I'm still willing
to like root for the show and give it
the benefit of the doubt yeah yeah um
yeah I was I was like um you know Henry Cavill
the only time I've never really dove into what
anyone was ever saying um but the only talk I
ever heard was that oh Henry cavill's leaving
um because of how much they're
straying away from the material
and then watching this I was like did Henry
Cavill leave because because it's just not as
good anymore I would not be at all surprised
and the thing is like I yeah like because I
felt like personally I thought season two as
a non-book reader um for all books [Laughter]
as a not as a non-liter reader of The Witcher I
thought it was a decent like I still way preferred
season one but I thought it was a decent
enough hybrid of what they were wanting to
achieve to make it more attainable for audiences I
personally this is like whoa no this is like three
colonelitis just do the movie version yeah yeah
and and as a non-book reader yeah it's that thing
where you're sitting there going I don't know
the source material but I bet it's not exactly
like this whereas like you watch the first season
you're like I don't know but it feels again it
feels literary and then a I agree the second
season still maintains some of that and this
just feels like you know one of the later Game
of Thrones season where they're just like just
cut around you know let's get some plots moving
yeah that was uh that was bumpy alrighty guys well
sad part is I heard this is the best episode
of the season oh no could be wrong maybe
they're all boys willing to disagree
with with whatever opinions I've heard
um I'm ready for a sleeper so yeah uh surprised
me with something great late I don't know maybe
this reaction series will be just us bagging on
the show now um rage watch The Witcher alrighty
guys well before we go uh let us know your
thoughts and um let's send this for the patreon
Brian Perry you sound like this is perfect I feel
like Brian is like the elemental version of this
name this you know like well-worn classic
name and you know how words and things warp
over the years but you're the original you're
like the that nugget that like you know little
Cornerstone of the sourdough that makes the
whole loaf over Generations after Generations
after Generations it was prophesied that
all subsequent Brian's stem from you
you are the chosen one you are the key we need
your Elder blood Brian Perry to uh both destroy
and restore everything you're the McGuffin of
the patreon and we appreciate you being here
and uh bringing us and chanting us each month
with your unique Magic love you buddy stay
pledged toss a coin to the patreon and we will
not count it matter how big the bag or small
as long as there's a bag we're happy love
you buddy till next time cheers [Music]